[Music]
here's a quick tip from someone we love
you can grow mint in the ground but this
is where we have our disclaimer from it
mint is a very aggressively growing
plant that means that where you plant
mint it will expand and it will pop up
all over your garden so my tip for you
in growing mint is to either grow it in
a pot
or grow it in a raised bed
if you don't want to dedicate a whole
raised bed to mint
you can actually bury
a pot
in the soil
and that will help keep mint in this
area we're gonna take your pot and your
pot can be as big as you want if you
want a bigger section of mint
if it's at soil level those runners
would expand right across the soil so
you want to leave it high up keeping
your mint in check if you don't want it
to take over
hey drew it's debay atkins and i'm
america's youngest certified yoga
teacher i just wanted to show you a few
chair yoga moves that you can do it's
really convenient if you're working at a
desk to stay active to stay mobile we're
going to start with our feet planted on
the mat handstand to your heart center
spine lengthen inhale reach your arms
over your head
exhale
twist to the right
bringing your right hand to your left
knee your left hand to the back of the
chair
inhale arms up
lengthen your spine
exhale
twist to the left
inhale reach your arms over your head
exhale
lower your right hand
down to the side of the chair you can
grab the leg
and reach your left arm over your head
inhale center
exhale other side lean to the left
inhale arms up
exhale
bend forward grabbing the front legs of
the chair
inhale
arms up arch your back leaning back this
helps keep your spine strong healthy and
flexible
think good thoughts
speak kind words
feel love be loved and give love
namaste
i love buying supermarket flowers and
making them into an expensive looking
flower arrangement i got white
hydrangeas and roses from costco picked
a large gold bowl put a clear vase
inside the bowl with water and used the
taping technique i then pulled the green
leaves off my hydrangeas then i trimmed
them and put them inside the bowl with
the water the taping technique holds the
flowers in place and helps fill up the
bowls faster i added my roses
i lit up my candle and here is how it
all looks in my kitchen
that's
genius why didn't i think of that
[Music]